this is a production of cornell
university
my name is zachary stancil and i am the
hemp curator at the usda agricultural
research service
so the work that we do in our laboratory
is to create
a
seed library for genetically diverse
hemp varieties from all around the world
additionally we are going to be studying
all of those diverse and unique
varieties of hemp for
all kinds of different traits that
plant breeders farmers and
during the course of the last couple
years that we've started this project
we've had just the tremendous honor of
meeting learning from and collaborating
with some of the most dynamic and
influential scientists entrepreneurs and
experts in the hymn world
so we are thrilled to share some of that
knowledge that we've gained in that
process with all of y'all
so i really want to thank um cornell
university for uh
co-partnering with us to make this
seminar hemp webinar series um
and i want to give my biggest shout out
to
all of our friends um
at
our hbcu institution so we've been
thrilled to see
how
these hbcu hemp programs are just
emerging as real powerhouses
so we wanted to make sure that
um y'all were invited to the to the to
the party and uh we're just so thrilled
to have everyone here
um so i it's my great pleasure to
introduce our speaker today
so dr bruce bugbee is a professor at
utah state university
and the president of apogee instruments
so he has a very illustrious background
he's collaborated with nasa for 40 years
to design food production systems for
people living on mars
in 2011 he was awarded the governor's
medal for science
and is a fellow of both the american
society of agronomy
and american society of horticulture
he has recorded multiple videos on
photobiological principles
one video on cannabis has over 2 million
views
so
one might argue that uh his pinnacle
achievement is summarizing
so much of this information and a ted
talk
called turning water into food
so after bruce's uh talk we are gonna
have a cueing
uh q a session so we're start thinking
of some great questions to stump him
i'm bruce bugbee and i'm pleased to be
giving this talk today
in the usda cornell
hemp seminar
on indoor production now you just heard
previously on outdoor production we're
going to go indoors
the first thing i want to say is
when we grow
low thc
compounds the current value
rarely justifies indoor production
but
there's a lot of other things that are
high value that do justify it and we
this is our the core of our studies and
when we say hemp in our case we're
always talking about medical hemp grown
for the highest value direct consumption
by people
so
it can get pretty valuable let me start
with a little diagram here when we say
indoor
what does that mean well to a lot of
people it means
no sunlight it means of electric lights
in a closed warehouse and a closed room
and i'm going to put that over here
here's our box and i and i guess i could
have put some
green plants in here too
inside the box and then since we're on a
roll
here's the sun
get the sun anatomically correct here
there's no sun in here all of this is
driven by electricity it's very
expensive to replicate sun
compared to
over here
a
greenhouse and now
we put the sun in this
and of course
the sun goes right in free sunlight
i've given several seminars on this most
recently one last october at cornell
university
and the title of that seminar was the
physics of farming without sunlight it's
recorded you can look that up online it
was part of the horticulture department
seminar series and i talked about this
trade-off between
farming without sunlight and
greenhouses
and if you listen to my seminars you'll
know that i'm a huge proponent of
greenhouses because we get free sunlight
this is high-tech greenhouses so i
should mention that
these are closed air conditioned
greenhouses
in which we elevate co2
so now both of these have high co2
they're life in the fast lane really
fast plant growth it's just that this
one uses free sunlight and it uses a lot
less fossil fuels so the future of this
i think is going to be high-tech
greenhouses
both are indoors and everything
i'm going to talk about is relevant to
both both of them use supplemental
lighting especially in the winter now
from leds
this has the great advantage of some
real high-tech glass not real high-tech
you buy it commercially but it reflects
thermal infrared radiation from the sun
so it's much easier to air
condition greenhouses now than it used
to be and when they air condition them
we control humidity and we can elevate
co2
so these are similar all right
there's the whole talk indoor production
two things but everything i say is
relevant to both
the
now
let's take a look at what i call the
nine cardinal parameters for growth i've
shown this slide several times and and
other people have used it um
so it's it's worth going through this
again
when we go inside we control all of
these parameters
and
uh
that's of significance is
co2
we elevate co2 that enhances
photosynthesis
30 percent maybe even 40 percent if it
allows us to use a higher temperature
when we elevate co2 because of
photorespiration
it's a huge
difference with indoor
also
we
might up here
control the light unlike outside the sun
comes up in the morning and we get we
can't control whether it's cloudy or not
we can control when we plant when we
harvest
indoors we have a huge control of light
with leds i'm going to talk about leds
in a minute we can turn up the leds and
really increase the light and wow
cannabis is an absolutely high light
crop it's like some
race car that you can drive 400 miles an
hour if you can pour enough light in but
when you put all that light in
the transpiration rate goes up so you
need more water need more water you need
more nutrients respiration the root zone
goes up you need more oxygen
that the optimum temperature is higher
you need more wind blowing through the
crop to help cool it
light drives everything it's a huge
factor and in this lab we spent a lot of
time studying
light
so that's a concept of all the things
you can do with indoor production to
elevate yield
there's our expensive inputs
particularly the light
but when the product is high value
all of this is economically justified
we have been studying in this lab
medical hemp which we also call low thc
cannabis it's all cannabis sativa the
same genus and species
the low thc
is what's federally legal now and that's
the
crop that we're studying at at
universities
that's in contrast to high thc cannabis
that is
psychoactive but
federally illegal so all of our licenses
for low thc when i say cannabis i'm
always referring to the low thc type
which has earned the nickname hemp but
hemp is for often for rope and for
clothes
so then we say medical hemp because this
is grown for pharmaceuticals
not for seed and fiber
this is such a big thing that
last year we developed and taught an
online course in
the science and technology of medical
cannabis cultivation
note capital c italicized that's the
name of the genus
this is the page
it's at cannabis.usu.edu
this course
is we got a lot of students this course
is now closed it's done
but as we speak we're working on a
second addition to this course and it'll
be posted here
but this website gives you
a more
in-depth view of some of the things i'm
going to talk about here
let's talk about leds this is a real
breakthrough and it's facilitated a
massive amount of supplemental lighting
for crops to push the growth this is a
curve
over the last
20 years
of leds and the electrical efficiency
it's gone from 10
here we are 2022
right up here now
how does this compare for other lighting
technologies
before this we used high pressure sodium
which is about 35 percent efficient and
you can see roughly 2010 leds caught up
in past high pressure sodium
and fluorescent is in the teens for
efficiency down in here
so this gives you some sense of how good
leds really are but it also gives you a
sense of where we're going
100 percent's a theoretical max we're
never going to quite get there but this
is our prediction
so we're close to
where we're going to get with leds
what's changing about leds is price
reliability
those kinds of factors the ability to
get the lights consistently up to 80
percent efficient this is just
remarkable consider that this 20
here
is still heat
people say leds don't put off any heat
yeah if you're an instrument
manufacturer you put them in they get
plenty hot even with 20
so but they're they're a wonderful
technology they allow us to do all kinds
of
amazing things with colors of light
and i'm going to show you some of those
things right now
spectral effects on photosynthesis i
love this dark side of the moon prism
breaking light up into colors for the
first time ever we can pinpoint these
colors
and and
really study their effects on plants
it's fascinating what they can do
and our recent research in this lab has
helped us
see some things that we we could not
have studied without leds
here's the a big one
far red photons
are these photons right here i should
draw that in
red deep red the photons right here
they're right at the edge of our vision
far red photons are like a red hot
burner on a stove hard to read a book by
them but but they're there
they're abundant in sunlight and now we
have a very very efficient far red led
historically we have said those are not
photosynthetic they cause shade
avoidance responses they don't cause
photosynthesis
we revisited that idea
we have been revisiting it over the past
several years
and i'm pleased to report that we're
proposing a new definition of
photosynthetic photons
this work it was the result of
shuyong zhen
who was a postdoc with us
for several years now she's assistant
professor at texas a m she's still
working on this and also mark van ersel
who was a postdoc in this lab like long
time ago i forget 20 30 years ago now
he's distinguished professor at the
university of georgia we are still
collaborating on this work
and to tell you how
the circles that we go in shu young got
her phd with mark van ersel and she came
here to do
photosynthesis research
here's the paper
that summarized all this
just published last year why far red
photons should be included in the
definition of photosynthetic radiation
this is a review paper
but co-authored by all of us
this is pretty in-depth but it's it's
fascinating because i want to share the
excitement of research with you this is
a huge finding for all of biology
look at what these colors do
this is a leaf and we'll put the leaf in
green
on here here's the bottom of the leaf
here's the top
blue and red photons are quickly
absorbed in the top of the leaf they're
very efficiently absorbed but they don't
penetrate they're so efficiently
absorbed whereas the green photons
penetrate deep into the leaf and when
you get another leaf down here they keep
going they keep penetrating into the
canopy so green photons are the value of
green is underrated look at far red
these also penetrate deep in the leaf
this is one of the reasons that these
photons are so good
this let's get rid of that
this
is there's two papers you can pause this
and see these papers but two papers on
the value of these far red photons
for photosynthesis and far red's almost
like a blow torch it's a real powerful
wavelength that now we can now add and
subtract when we do electric lights in
greenhouses
summary of spectral effects i'm taking
a dozen lectures and compressing them
into minutes
this was
helped out by paul kasuma a recent phd
student in the lab he's now research
scientist at wageningen university in
the netherlands
but he helped us out a lot
during his phd year let's take
these five categories of light and go
through them
uv
induces photoprotective pigments in
plants
and some of those photo protective
pigments could be cannabinoids because
they absorb uv light
uv light turns green lettuce red
that's anthocyanin
i will say that we don't have any
evidence from multiple studies in this
lab
that more uv can trigger cannabinoid
synthesis even though people think that
it does and our results are now
consistent with other labs on that
blue
inhibits cell expansion this is a if you
want to keep plants small and short you
can do it with blue and i think i have a
picture here's cannabis
thirty percent blue five percent blue
look at that difference in height you
can shrink the plants make them compact
with blue light
when you do that you have to plant at a
higher density but these are all
trade-offs with
manipulating the shape
green
is key because it facilitates human
vision
here's some blue lights blue and red you
can't the plants look black there's the
green photons beautiful plants example
of how critical green light is
we used to grow plants under purple
light blue and red and now that's so
difficult that we
now add white leds to fixtures so we can
see the plants i think i have another
picture here
this is cannabis
under a high pressure sodium light and
under some leds and you can see the
difference in color here these are just
look more natural the growth
was the same it didn't matter
but in this study we got some spider
mites a microscopic insect
we couldn't see those on the high
pressure sodium lights but here in the
leds with a better color rendering index
we could find the insects we can also
diagnose nutritional disorders so the
bottom line is
green photons are huge
for helping people see disorders and and
microscopic insects in plants
manufacturers are starting to put
information now in their pictures
but the color rendering index this is
obviously huge for people
and for years we've said oh it just
doesn't matter for plants
yeah it does
i love the chinese saying
the best fertilizer is the footsteps of
the farmer
and if you can't see the plants your
footsteps don't help much
red photons are the meat and potatoes of
the diet the potatoes of the diet
they're very efficient for
photosynthesis the red leds are
efficient many of our our fixtures now
are 80 to 90 percent red leds
both because they're electrically
efficient and and quickly absorbed by
the plants and then far red photons
which are photosynthetic do the opposite
of blue these inhibit these enhance so
we can play with those two colors of
light to shape plants tall short fat
thin
wide it's a it's a wonderful time to be
doing research on this to optimize
colors and plant shape
now i want to switch to amount of light
this is amazing story with cannabis
no other crop
benefits from the highlight the way
cannabis does
and what this graph shows you is
daily light integral this is the amount
of light per day
and yield up here
other crops would look
like that
they would saturate at a much lower
level of light
cannabis keeps growing we've done this
many times this requires whole rooms
with whole communities of plants to do
this but our data coupled now with that
of some other labs indicate we can push
cannabis hard with high light let me
give you a sense of how high this is
on the brightest days in the summer
sunny days no clouds
we can get up to 60
right here
so we've exceeded a full sunny day in
the summer and this is near the summer
solstice the average in the field is
more like
40 or 50. this would be a field average
in full sunlight
somewhere down here especially toward
the end of the year
in a greenhouse that blocks
half of the light
the average is down here i'm going to
put green gh greenhouse
which is about 30 and that's with no
supplemental light
but grown in the summer and of course in
the winter we're down here in indoors
less than 10.
moral of the story wow here is a crop we
can push with uh highlight
and push hard
interestingly enough in this data let's
let's erase those lines
in this data
we we measured harvest index now
this is the ratio of flower yield to
total biomass
as the light went up
harvest index also went up
guess what in our major crop plants
corn
soybeans well not so much soybeans but
high
yielding crops corn
the harvest index is down in here in in
this zone
so cannabis is quite remarkable a real
high ratio of flowers to total weight
and that went up with light
here's what the plants look like at low
light not surprisingly spindly small
flowers we increased the light boy these
were just short and compact and huge
colas on these plants once we get up to
70. this is worked on by which
mitch westmoreland
who is a current phd student in the lab
if you were measuring lights
a daily light integral the total photons
in the day
of 70
would be 1
600
micromoles per meter squared per second
at a 12 hour photo period
this number right here we call the ppfd
photosynthetic photon
flux density this is what we measure
that's amazing
that's 80 percent of full sunlight the
whole time when these plants are in here
this is just stunning no other crop is
like this at least none that we have
studied now i will say this is with high
co2 all of our work is done with high
co2 because it's immediately
economically feasible
and important to elevate the co2 so that
is not limiting
in here
what did this do to quality when we push
the plants this hard you might think the
quality would go down it did not yield
went up
here is
cbd 15
flat line
over this whole dli up to 70. didn't go
up didn't go down stayed the same
here's thc also a flat line very
slightly up
now if you're an astute watcher what's
the
us legal limit
for
hemp for low thc
0.03 percent
there's the legal limit right there
these plans exceed the legal limit we're
pushing them hard
we do not sell hemp we destroy all the
hemp and so our license lets us get up
to above 0.3
but
and of course you got to be real careful
not to exceed 0.3 for a medical hemp
but this is an example of what happens
when we push the
lights hard now cbg
is the precursor to both of these if i
do arrows on here
this is the precursor to both of these
wow look at that an increased
like 40 percent with highlights so these
plants are making a lot of cannabinoids
this is the ratio cbd to thc which we
pay attention to a lot
we want the thc to be low so it's legal
we want the cbd to be high lots of
people make all kinds of claims about
this ratio but this line is really
pretty flat and right at about 25
to 1 cbd to thc here's what the flowers
look like
boy
dense colas that highlight and at low
light pretty spindly
colas
yeah looks like i'm
uh 25 minutes
let's take a look at a couple other
amazing things that are relevant to the
field
we have been doing a series of studies
on
degree days in cannabis now we use
degree days and lots of horticultural
crops it's just the temperature
multiplied by the number of days
so
one hot day is equal to two cold days
that's the concept and we take
temperature times time and we call it
degree days and that concept predicts
the rate of development time to
flowering in a lot of our horticultural
crops
what does it do in cannabis
so we recently completed a study when i
say we this means mitch westmoreland he
did the work
um
wildly different temperatures really
pretty warm down to really cold these
are in celsius this is oh in the 80s and
down into the 50s in fahrenheit a huge
range of temperatures
and all the data fit one curve
the
rate of development meaning flower mass
is on a steady curve predicted
by thermal time also called degree days
this is uh quite remarkable that
regardless of
the extremes of temperature if we add up
degree days we can predict rate of
development of the crop
this by the way was all done
at a 12 hour photo period this is going
to interact with photo period too but in
a controlled environment we can set the
photo period to 12 hours
phosphorus this is huge
cannabis growers are famous for over
fertilizing with phosphorus
for those of us studying nutrition at
universities
we have long encouraged
field growers to put on less phosphorus
because it's a horrible environmental
pollutant
and
it's
universally people put on more
phosphorus than they need the runoff
causes it to end up in
lakes and rivers and algal blooms it's a
bad story now we bring in cannabis
growers
we have seen cannabis growers put an
order of magnitude more phosphorus on
cannabis than you would for any other
crop
so we started studying this many series
of studies
this is in liquid fertilizer now
not in a in a field rate
but most of our crops
in here are grown
with phosphorus
in in this range i'm going to put
optimal here
and this includes dozens and dozens of
crops down in here is optimal we have
found cannabis does indeed respond to
more phosphorus
but only from about
15
ppm to 30.
now we don't have data down here but
30 ppm
is
beneficial to phosphorus
going higher than that had no value this
is a non-significant slope of the line
it looks like it slopes down but it's
really statistically flat
we have not seen
a value of these incredibly high
phosphorus levels
and really we're waiting for people to
announce the growers to announce that
they grow sustainable phosphorus the
sustainable cannabis not over fertilized
with the
phosphorus
this is tricky business though because
there are
some cultivars
that appear to have benefit from higher
phosphorus
not it's not the norm but there's some
cultivars and in those cultivars let me
see let's put that in red
this line slopes slightly up
but the majority are a flat line we're
still studying this
let me show you what we know
since i've got a
minute here to show you
here's a here's a plant
let's see we're going to make this
simple we're going to put one leaf up
here
and then we're going to have the flower
bud right here very simple plant
in the later stages of development
phosphorous
shown here in red
moves out of the leaves into the flower
even though there's ample pea in here
when we track this over time
the flowers are cannibalizing the leaves
for phosphorus and you think well okay
if the flower needs a lot of phosphorus
this is a good thing
but these levels in the leaves
get to be one percent phosphorus or more
way more than could ever be used the
optimum in the leaves is about 0.3
percent
and the leaves are doing all the work
they're full of enzymes they're full of
nucleic acids they need a lot of
phosphorus
the flowers shouldn't need any more than
point three percent but they accumulate
massive amounts of phosphorus
we think what's happening is
plants that grow seeds
supply their seeds with very high
phosphorus to give them a good start in
life the seeds are packed with
phosphorus so they germinate and they
have adequate phosphorus when they're a
young seedling
here we go with cannabis
feminized plants no seeds
the plant still panics and moves
phosphorus into this flower
and it's it's useful as phosphorus but
if it's cannibalizing the leaves it
reduces yield
but
these super high levels are not
beneficial and
here's the amount of pee
you give them an optimal level and
there's minimal leaching and
tremendous leaching um
eat both from the field and from indoor
cultivation from this
i think if we extrapolate to the field
from this
i think we could roughly put pounds per
acre
if you're listening in the united states
and you're still using our ancient units
of pounds and acres
this is roughly similar to kilograms per
hectare
don't over fertilize with phosphorus
please
one final topic
silicon
si
not an essential element
but
generally abundant in field soils now we
go to a greenhouse and we are in
a container
we
rock wall peat based media coconut choir
perlite a lot of things
none of them
have
adequate silica for the plants and as a
rule of thumb silicon dioxide is glass
so
soluble silica goes into the plants
and really strengthens cell walls we we
know this from many years of study
one of the huge things it does is
disease resistance
you can almost eliminate powdery mildew
with ample silica in the root zone we've
seen it multiple times
growers had an outbreak of powdery
mildew and you say what's going on well
it turns out their silicon injector
broke and it stopped and the disease
came back um
it helps with
we got biotic stress abiotic stress
helps them make the plants more tolerant
of certain insects
mitigates heavy metal toxicity we're
always worried about that we want the
medical hemp to be clean clean clean
silica helps it with that
stress tolerance now let me show you an
amazing picture this is from jonathan
france who is a phd student in this lab
some years ago this is the reference you
can
pause on this boom
this happens to be with zinnia
i don't have a picture with with this
with cannabis but cannabis got a lot of
trichomes look at this
silica this thing is like a rhinoceros
without silica it's susceptible to
disease and insects so
when we grow
in a soilless media
we want to be adding silica to that
media
to help the plants be
rugged like they are in the field
now remember where the
cannabinoids are
if i if i do a little picture here
they're in trichomes
and one of those trichomes made out of
silica
so cannabis in particular
benefits from ample silica in the
root zone the trichomes get tougher as
well
have silica is hard to add it's not very
soluble um we
recently have a paper on how to get it
in
liquid fertilizer systems um with an
injector so you can put it in liquid
fertilizer but
we have found
building on the work of other
laboratories
that we'll astonite a natural mineral is
a tremendous source of silica just
ground will austenite here's the mineral
ground it rendered up its calcium
silicate
and this goes into solution
as calcium and this is silicic acid
this is
bio-available silica and while austenite
is slow release
look at this peat perlite coconut choir
vermiculite hardly any silica down here
there's there's well austenite this is
vancelle w10 this is a brand name of an
american velocinate mind in
new york
and it's it's sold for horticulture uses
like this but
and this is look at it 160 days it was
still
releasing silica this is a wonderful
product
we put it in our media
at
actually the the brand name we use is
cell 10
we put it in our media at one gram per
liter
i know that's metric units but you can
convert to
whatever other
numbers you want
here's the there's the low rate here
one final slide
this is our campus
cornell i was there again last fall is a
beautiful campus
so are we and this is the wellsville
mountains right here
my house is right over in here in this
picture um
if you're interested in cannabis i
invite you to
come here to graduate school um
we
love collaborating with people
this is a fascinating crop with an
exciting future
and in some ways we're using controlled
environments to predict plant responses
to the environment that and we're using
cannabis as a model crop for this
thanks for listening i now i'll look
forward to your questions
i can think i i believe i can speak for
everyone that uh
dr bugbee always gives a mind-blowing
uh presentation and today was no
different whatsoever um so thank you for
that that that got my
creativity and curiosity going on so
many different levels
um so i see a
ton of questions in the chat i think
george and tony are going to try to
field those to bruce
wait and by the way we should be back
live right
yep we can hear you loud and clear yep
uh all right and you uh so our first
question is from angela goodwin uh she
asked what is the definition of medical
hemp versus hemp does the term involve
the proposed use such as cbd oil
there this is more of a
economic distinction than a botanical
distinction
but
historically when we've said
hemp
we mean
growing it for rope and and and we're
mostly growing it for rope uh if you
look in the literature there's
there's ads by the
federal government
the navy needs the rope grow him for to
make him for the navy this was like
before world war ii
and it was a huge campaign to grow a lot
of hemp nationwide
because the fibers cotton fibers are
like three inches long hemp fibers are
like they can be three feet long i mean
that's why it makes such rugged clothing
and rugged material honestly i think has
a huge future
and i think we're going to see hemp
gradually start to replace cotton for
clothes
has deeper roots than cotton i think it
can be more water use efficient that's
another matter but
but when we say hemp we think of rope
historically
so then we start calling it medical hemp
which god that started to be illegal
before world war ii
and everything shut down and we went
through decades of this is terrible
stuff nobody should be growing it well
then guess what we got dupont polyester
we didn't need him for rope so much
anymore
but
the distinction then we say medical hemp
because of its end use it's not
botanical it's the end use
for cbd and other cannabinoid
products
botanically again they're both cannabis
sativa
we have lines and and cornell is a
leader in studying this
that really make good fiber that'll make
good clothes and we're putting it in
concrete now instead of rebar man should
what a wonderful time maybe botanical
products to build houses
that's all
hemp
with the historical term when we say
medical that means we're going to use it
for pharmaceuticals
and we our breeding programs head in a
different direction we don't care if it
makes fiber anymore we want to focus on
the
medical part of it
i have to look to the side because
that's where i got the screen
alrighty we have a question from
uh anna maria have you studied the
effect of far red light on cannabinoid
production and or flower size
yes we have and
i talked a lot about far red light in
photosynthesis um but i also said it's
like a blowtorch
when you take a plant science course and
especially maybe a plant physiology
course
you learn that far red light is very
enriched in shade underneath the tree
and what happens to plants when they
grow in the shade i can draw it right
here and see if i got my screen
here's a tree
here's the shade
these plants get tall
fast because of enriched far red light
so now experimentally we give them more
far red in that and most plants panic
they think they're in the shade and they
get real tall and that's almost always a
bad thing
we can give far red light to lettuce and
it just keeps getting bigger
horizontally
so we have to use far red light very
carefully
it doesn't have a direct effect on
cannabinoids
it has mostly effect on plant shape
and so we what we'd like to do is have a
nice
compact plant over here and we have to
be careful not to get use too much far
red and get the plants too tall
alrighty our next question is from felix
akins what is your experience with photo
damage or photo inhibition in cannabis
make my line slightly smaller here
cannabis has less
photo inhibition than many other crops
which is why we could do that remember
how i had that graph and that the amount
of light is here and and the yield is
like this
this is the danger zone up here where we
get so much light it's too much and it
starts burning leaves and it causes a
problem
but
cannabis apparently has sufficient photo
protective pigments
that we can push it hard with light and
and get higher yields keep in mind now
that this is under electric lights
which
we don't give them very much uv light in
the sun they get a lot of uv
the sunlight
sunlight has something like
eight percent uv
and electrically we can just take that
out we just don't get many uv so all of
a sudden it could be damaging in
sunlight to go this high but if we give
them the equivalent of sunlight without
the uv
we can push them harder
it's a big it's a big topic because
there was an early paper
by lyden l-y-d-o-n
leiden at all
and they it was 50 not 50 40 years ago
but they studied
high
uv
and cannabinoids
and they were only doing leaves and then
they got really low levels but in one of
their lines high uv increased
cannabinoid production
um but in the other line it didn't do
anything and
so
they they concluded in their paper the
effect of uv on cannabinoids is not
certain but everybody says well the
leiden paper proved it helps so there's
a case of you got to read the paper to
be good have good scholarship
alrighty this is a kind of related
question from erica hernandez has a
saturation point been found for ppfd
versus growth
what is required to determine the point
of diminishing returns monetarily for
added supplemental added supplemental or
soul lice light source
so now i guess i can draw that graph
again here's the increasing light
but now we could put a dollar sign here
for the cost of that light
if if we're doing it with supplemental
and we can put a dollar sign over here
for yield
and
clearly this line
if it was exactly like that it wouldn't
matter but it's not exactly like that it
starts here
and it goes like this so that the
economic optimum
is really something
more like that it's a curved
line and
economically some point in the middle is
an economic optimum
again because here you got to pay the
electric bill
and in the sun
we get up in this part of the curve for
free in the in the summer
this is part of the reason cannabis is
just such a vigorous plant it
it just grows enormously goes big in the
field
already a couple people asked about um
what concentration
do you think is high co2 do you start
the co2 high or do you increase it as
the plants get large
yeah well if you ever take a class from
me you know i'm constantly drawing x y
plots so now we do the same thing here's
co2
that's a c
here's 400 which is what we get for free
outside
and let's go all the way up here to 2
000. now these units are parts per
million
so way high five five times higher than
the field
and here's photosynthesis pnet we'll put
right here
so there's some point in here where it
gets to zero
um
and then
this curve
looks like that
and right about here
that this pro curve is probably
something like this
1200
is is pretty much the saturation point
uh this depends a little bit on
temperature
but so but enriching from 400 to 1200
look i've i've roughly drawn this but
look at this this is a huge increase
in photosynthesis and growth and biomass
production by elevating co2 which is one
of the keys of indoor
agriculture is to realize this big
increase
now one other thing if you don't elevate
in co2
this graph
goes
the other direction
plants take co2 out of the air
and that the room drops below 400 you'd
just be amazed i've seen rooms regularly
go to 200
and wow
not doing anything is bad news because
they suffocate it's like having people
in a closed box they run out of oxygen
so if you don't enrich you're going this
direction
and if you do enrich you're going
that direction
great uh we have another question how
important is it to change the
temperature during the day and the night
is it recommended to set up one single
temperature for indoor growing all the
time or
would it be better to set up a lower
temperature during the dark period good
good question
historically with research on other
crops tomatoes lettuce cucumbers we
always give a cooler night
but that's to save money we don't have
to heat the greenhouse so much at night
and cannabis is so high value that that
extra heat is not a big consideration
we have not found
any advantage of a cooler night
temperature the plant is generally
averaging the temperatures so we
typically
have a constant temperature day and
night
now we're still researching this
there's disease issues there's
condensation at night there's a lot of
interacting factors but just from the
straight physiology
we haven't found any value of having a
warmer day and a cooler night
that's that's the quick answer
uh another question
uh curious about phosphorus partitioning
do other field crops cannibalize tea to
floral parts precede
yeah another good question
yes
all plants
try to give their seeds a good start in
life
and
so they pack the phosphorus into the
seeds during the final weeks of maturity
so those little seeds have a bag lunch
they have a lot of phosphorus to start
and this is all a good thing for
vigorous seeds
and so all plants do this
but
cannabis is unique
first of all with field crops there's
only so much a seed can hold but now we
go to cannabis with a big clump of flour
and no seeds
and the plant we call it panicking it's
still thinking oh my god i got to move
flowers up there
phosphorus up there for the seeds but
there aren't any seeds so it toss it
looks like it over compensates
that's something you can help us with in
breeding so we don't keep the plant from
panicking about this phosphorus at the
end
but all of our data suggests it's
cannibalizing the leaves for no for no
uh gain
and it's why we end up having to put
more phosphorus on
great uh can you comment on the use of
silica in soil media cultivation
practices and if it is compatible with
usda organic certification
yeah
i'm not super familiar with all the
organic
certifications
but we'll austinite is a mineral and
i've got to think that's pretty safe
it's just a ground-up mineral we put on
rock phosphate all the time that's a
that's a legal thing
so i would expect
a ground-up mineral like velocinate
would be compatible with
organic certifications and it might that
might be well known i just haven't
looked at it i know a lot of people are
starting to use it
um
question about do does ideal ppfd or
environmental conditions change in the
last few weeks before harvesting
yeah this is another really interesting
question and
we get into the
astute observations of
historic cannabis growers we call them
the heritage growers they were growing
it before it was legal
and they don't necessarily have any
background in the principles of plant
science but they're keen observers
and they've done all kinds of things
with light one of the things is put the
plants in the dark for a few days prior
to harvest
that's very unusual i mean
photosynthesis stops um
if if there's anything going on with
that it's an indirect effect
on conversely giving them ample light
toward the end
you could make a case for that because
now photosynthesis is high right before
harvest it could help quality of the
crops
but
the leaves are old and tired by that
time so we it's like
putting a grandpa on steroids so he can
run the hundred yard dash fast well
steroids help but would they help that
grandpa well maybe he should have got
him
earlier in the life cycle
so
it's interesting to add light when a
plant is sort of in the senescence phase
but some people argue for doing it
great uh another question have you
looked at any other cannabinoids for
indoor growth like barren cannabinoids
like what kind of cannabinoids uh baron
cannabinoids
we've yeah we haven't done a ton of
studies on minor cannabinoids
keep in mind
here
cbg
goes to thc
cbd
and cbc
this is real minor this is a teeny arrow
these are great big arrows
here
and then these in turn go to other
things in in the biochemistry
these two here are 90
of the total cannabinoids in plants
so these the other things that come out
of this
from other biochemical pathways are real
interesting pharmaceutically trace
amounts of cbn
can be pharmaceutically important
we have not yet done much
looking at
manipulating the minor cannabinoids it's
something we're eager to get going on
but we focused mostly on these two right
here
i think that answers
the question
we have a couple questions about other
um other potentially limiting nutrients
such as uh calcium or potassium could
you comment on that yeah boy that what
you guys are really asking good
questions
in in all of plant physiology all of us
teach
potassium is actively taken up and
plants will accumulate huge amounts of
potassium
calcium is passively taken up
and and we have a hard time getting
enough calcium into many crop plants
to put in lettuce lack of calcium is tip
burn in tomatoes lack of calcium is
blossom end rot we have a whole long
list of serious disorders from low
calcium now we bring in cannabis
and it turns the world upside down
in all of our studies with hydroponics
cannabis accumulates calcium as if it
was actively absorbed
i mean calcium is adequate at one or two
percent in leaves we've seen cannabis
leaves at eight percent calcium it's
amazing doesn't seem to be toxic but
this is just an amazing and it depletes
the solution of calcium so do we need to
give it more or is it
i think not we keep giving it more it
can can't control its appetite for
calcium
conversely potassium
is slowly absorbed by cannabis what a
fascinating thing from a plant
physiology standpoint in terms of its
ratio of taking up
nutrients but it sure takes up calcium
fast and we don't have any of the
standard calcium deficiencies in
cannabis that we do in
all kinds of other horticultural crops
alrighty we're getting to our our 3 p.m
eastern time here so we'll have one last
question
um would it be beneficial to grow hemp
under 24 hours of lights
god another great question we'd probably
go on for hours with these questions
first of all it's a short day crop so we
need short days to get it to flower if
we just did 24 hours all the time we'd
get a massive crop and no flowers
so
we need short taste to get it flower now
do we need exactly 12 hours or can we go
13 could we go 14 and in depends on the
cultivar and now we're going to work
with breeders like everybody at cornell
and the usda
to develop lines that can take longer
photo periods
if we give the plants
24 hours of light late in the life cycle
we have seen them revert instead of
growing more flowers they start to grow
more leaves
so the quick answer to this is no we
can't we can't grow it in 24 hours of
light it's too bad because we could get
the daily light integral really high
with continuous light but the plant
reverts to growing leaves again
already well i i think we're at our end
time here so i'll thank uh dr bugbee
again for a fantastic talk and thank you
all for attending for all the um
fantastic questions uh just a reminder
in two weeks at the same time we'll have
dr heather grad talking about
hemp processing systems and
this video will be posted on youtube
if you'd like to watch it again
thank you all thanks again bruce yes
thanks for putting this together nice
job
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu